what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about every known race / species
in the world of black clover including
humans elves demons and more in recent
chapters of the manga new races have
been introduced into the story and it is
quite possible that even more might be
introduced in the future but until then
I will explain everything you need to
know about all the currently known races
/ species in the black Laura's story if
you enjoyed the black clover content on
this channel and you want to see more
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell also you can follow us
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest news and updates
finally this video will contain manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned first up we have
the humans who are by far the largest
race in the story when it comes to
numbers the humans control all of the
known nations in the world of black
clover and it is likely that the sheer
size of the human race is what led to
them eventually dominating the entire
world of black clover in general the
humans are not the strongest known race
and there are various different
subcategories of the human race itself
it is important to note that along with
being the most populous race the humans
also appear to have the most advanced
technology and it is likely that both
their large population and advanced
technology contributed to the fact that
humans became dominant in the world of
black clover in terms of subcategories
let's start with the regular humans or
commoners nearly all commoners have some
amount of mana although the amount
depends on the individual person very
rarely a human is born without any mana
altogether and of course hasta is one
example of that but it is important to
stress that this is a rare occurrence
and not the norm even among commoners
the humans who live in the outermost
region of the clover kingdom known as
the Forsaken realm tend to be the
weakest and poorest members
the clover kingdom but that doesn't mean
that extremely powerful mages cannot
emerge from the forsaken realm you know
is a perfect example of someone who was
raised in the forsaken realm all his
life but still possesses an immense
amount of mana and magic potential after
the commoners we have the royal families
we know that at least in the clover
kingdom members of royal families tend
to have more mana ie
a higher magic amount on average when
compared to non Royals and this is why
many members of royal families become
extremely powerful mages a lot of Royals
although thankfully not all of them
considered themselves to be inherently
better and more powerful than commoners
because of their royal birth and status
Royals are generally all expected to be
highly successful in powerful mages and
any royal who is born without great
magic potential is looked down upon by
the other Royals even if her oil does
possess a lot of mana but they can't
quite control their magic yet or they
possess a unique power that is not
properly understood as was the case with
Noel and Sakura respectively these
Royals will likely still face ridicule
from other Royals another subcategory of
humans that has to be mentioned is of
course the witches the witches are human
women who live inside the witches forest
which is a grand magic zone that is
located in a neutral area between the
clover and diamond kingdoms the witches
forest is ruled by the witch queen and
the woman who live inside the witches
forest are supposed to only live there
when a which leaves the forest like
vanessa did she is considered a fugitive
from the witch queen technically
speaking men and non witches are not
allowed inside the witch's forest but as
we know that didn't stop austin friends
from going in any way the witches tend
to have the type of magic that we would
associate with witches in our own world
such as magic that revolves around
curses or fortune-telling finally we
have the humans whose bodies were
altered through cruel experimentation
like Mars and fauna these humans had
mage stones implanted into their bodies
by the diamond kingdom and this enhances
their magical abilities but it also
affects their personality next up we
have the el
the elves also known as the elf tribe
are an ancient race who had lived in the
forsaken realm of the clover kingdom up
until some 500 years ago the elves look
a lot like humans other than the fact
that they all have white hair and pointy
ears and their genetic makeup is close
enough to the genetic makeup of humans
that an elf and a human can have
children together as we saw with length
the leader of the elf tribe and tete Tia
the sister of the first wizard King the
elves in general have a lot more magic
power than humans but as mentioned
earlier humans are far more numerous
than elves and humans have more advanced
technology the elves are believed to be
the only creatures who are able to use
magic stones to their fullest extent and
the elves also have knowledge of ancient
and forbidden magic that requires
immense amounts of mana such as the
creation of a third eye because of their
immense magical abilities the elves were
once revered by humans but some humans
were also afraid of the elves and
jealous of their power as a result the
devil was able to manipulate the elves
on the humans in order to orchestrate
the elf massacre five centuries prior to
the events of black clover many of the
elves including Patri did not realize
that the massacre had been orchestrated
by the devil and they blamed the humans
for betraying them on top of their
normal forms and the three-eyed form
there are several other forms that elves
can transform into after the elf
massacre Licht was able to use the magic
stones to transform himself into a giant
demon also known as the demon God in
this form licked becomes a mindless
monster bent on destruction and he is
ultimately killed by Lumiere the first
wizard King it is worth noting that the
reason lick turned himself into this
monster was to stop the devil from
taking control of his body taking on
this form and being killed by Lumiere
was the only way to stop the devil from
incarnated into this world finally we
have the Dark Elf form because creatures
who have been brought back to life
through reincarnation magic are stricken
with wicked hearts their negative
emotions will be amplified and their
personalities will be more susceptible
to such negative feelings as jealousy
despair and hatred
once an elf who has been reincarnated
becomes fully corrupted by these
negative emotions he or she transforms
into a dark elf so far the only example
we've seen Oh a dark elf form was Patri
after he learned the truth about the
devil's manipulation of him and his
emotions in this form Patri skin becomes
darker his light magic becomes demon
light magic which is a dark and sinister
version of light magic and the whites of
his eyes turned black in the Dark Elf
form Patri appears to be bent on
mindless destruction without any emotion
or remorse which is kind of similar to
lifts a giant demon form but Austin is
able to get through the poetry after his
anti magic allows him to enter Patras
mind after that pot reappears to revert
back to his normal form although his
left eye remains black while the other
eye goes back to normal
judging by what we've seen so far it is
quite possible that the elves have even
more tricks up their sleeve and that
their knowledge of ancient and forbidden
magic may allow them to assume unknown
forms and transformations that we still
haven't even seen yet now let's talk
about the demons or Devils the Akuma
translated as either Devils or demons
appears to be another ancient race of
extremely powerful magical beings other
than licks giant demon form the only
demons that we have seen in the series
so far is the devil who had possessed
Ronan and orchestrated the elf massacre
and the demon who is trapped inside of
Austin's grimoire these two demons
appear to have some physical
similarities such as horns sharp teeth
and giant dark wings we now know that
both the devil and Austin's demon come
from another dimension so they are not
originally from this world they were
somehow able to come into this world
they are able to possess the bodies of
other creatures such as humans and elves
and they're also able to possess certain
objects such as a five leaf grimoire
because it is said that within the fifth
leaf lies the devil we can assume that
for a demon to enter this dimension from
their own dimension a five leaf grimoire
is required although we don't know
anything about the demon world or why
the demons from their wood
want to travel to this dimension in the
first place one thing is certain the
demons possess incredibly powerful and
rare otherworldly powers such as the
Devils kotodama magic and asked us
demons anti magic then we have the
dwarves another ancient race that once
lived alongside the humans and the elves
but now appears to be nearly extinct is
the dwarf race like the elves the
dwarves are humanoid and their
appearance is very similar to humans
their biology is also similar enough to
human biology for the two species to
have children together and we now know
that charming puppets in' is half human
and half dwarf very little is known
about the dwarves other than the fact
that they appear to be shorter on
average than humans and the fact that
they appear to have unique magical
skills and abilities due to the fact
that she is half human and half dwarf
Charmy is able to use two distinct forms
of magic cotton magic and food magic it
is interesting to note that the devil
mockingly referred to Austin as a dwarf
because of his short stature and some
fans believe that this means that hasta
is actually a dwarf or half dwarf
however the devil may have been just
mocking asked us height rather than
seriously calling him a dwarf so we do
have to keep that in mind as far as we
know so far
hasta is human but he is one of those
very rare humans who was born without
any magical power at any rate I can't
wait to learn more about the dwarves in
the future and finally we have the
spirits the spirits are extremely rare
creatures who are summoned in order to
increase the power of elemental magic it
would be wrong to call the spirits a
race in and of themselves but because
they are a very unique type of creature
in the black lower story I decided to
talk about them here so far we've been
introduced to only two spirits sylph the
wind spirit and salamander the fire
spirit it is possible that there is a
spirit for every single type of magic
including water earth and so on but we
are yet to meet these other spirits we
know that spirits are highly intelligent
and powerful creatures and that their
powers and personalities evolve along
with the user to whom they are
hatched you know encountered the wind
spirit sylph inside a dungeon and she
appears to have been summoned by
powerful ancient magic she has since
grown very attached to you know and she
appears to have a romantic crush on him
as well the fire spirit salamander was
first used by the elf fauna but control
of the spirit is later transferred to
Foucault Leon Vermillion unlike sylph
who has the appearance of a humanoid
fairy or pixie salamander has the
appearance or an orange lizard and as he
becomes more powerful salamander can
turn into a huge winged dragon big
enough to carry passengers on its back I
am very curious to see how many more
spirits there are in the black lower
story and what their unique powers and
appearance will be and those are all the
races and species and black Lords that
we know about so far even though our
knowledge of most of the other races and
species aside from the humans and elves
is very limited for now the fact that
humans elves and Dwarfs all have a
biology that is similar enough for them
to have children amongst themselves
means that there are likely some
extremely interesting hybrid creatures
walking around out there in the world of
black clover creatures like the amazing
Charmy puppets in' let me know what you
guys think what is your favorite race /
species in black clovers so far which do
you like best humans elves demons
dwarves spirits and what other races do
you think could be introduced in black
clover in the future orcs faeries
otaku's let me know down in the comments
if you enjoy the black color content on
this channel you can leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell I want to thank
the visual editor of this video Dakota
broski for being awesome and for helping
us bring more content to you here on
anime uproar Dakota is one of the
several editors that have been
instrumental in allowing us to produce
far more videos than we used to so
please show the co dubrovsky some love
and follow his youtube channel his
channel is anime focused and it is top
tier quality web content I will link the
channel in the description so go over
there and show the man some love a huge
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for supporting our work I want
to give a special thank you to our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only
chops is the man nothing but a fan and
Jason Wilson and another huge thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
baby ray ace in grata a lowland Adam
Maddy Mac and Michael Calderon if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime up for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see our space cowboys
[Music]